بيحتفل العالم في الثامن من مارس اليوم
بمناسبه غاليه على قلب الكل يوم المراه
العالمي واللي اسمها هاشتاقاتو بكل اللغات
ما هي المنصات ترند في جميع الدول احتفاء
بانجازاتها على جميع الاصعده فكل عام وانا
وكل نساء العالم بالف خير وكل عام والنساء
العالم مشرقين ومزدهرين ومن نجاح لنجاح في
تفاعلكم طبعا مو غايب عن بالنا ابدا كم
الصعوبات والمعوقات والازمات اللي لسه
بتعانيها المراه حول العالم وجزء اساسي من
قضايانا في البرنامج هنا هو انه نسلط
الضوء عليها لكن اليوم حابين نحتفل ونحتفل
بس يعني ما نتكلم عن صعوبات وماسي في يوم
المراه العالمي كالعاده اول المحتفلين كان
جوجل اللي غير شعاره مثل ما شايفين واحتفى
بانجازات المراه ودورها في كل مكان وزمان
كام كعامله كممرضه كسياسيه وغيرها من
المهن ومثل كل عام في شعار بيكون خاص بيوم
المراه والشعار بيكون وراء قصه وهدف وهذه
السنه اطلقت الامم المتحده شعار اشراك
الجميع رقميا الابتكار والتقنيه لتحقيق
المساواه بين الجنسين
الامم المتحده قالت انها اختارت هذه
العنوان للاحتفال السنه لانه رغم اهميه
الانترنت في العالم وانتشاره لكن لسه في
37% من نساء العالم ما بيستخدموه وستات
اقل من الرجال ب 259 مليون بيستخدموا
الانترنت هذه الفروقات الامم المتحده
سمتها فجوه رقميه بين الرجال والنساء
وعليه قررت ان السنه يكون الاحتفال عن
طريق الدعوه لاشراك المراه اكثر في هذا
المجال سواء في التعليم او تطوير المهارات
او العمل في المجالات التكنولوجيه وكان
نشر الموقع رساله من الامين العام انطونيو
غواترف انه الاستثمار في المراه بينهض
بجميع الناس
والدول حتى والبلدان كافه
اما للي حابب يعرف ايش هي اصلا قصه يوم
المراه العالمي فالقصه ترجع لي 8 مارس عام
1856 لما طلعت الالاف من النساء في شوارع
مدينه نيويورك للاحتجاج على الظروف اللا
انسانيه اللي بينجبروا على العمل فيها وتم
تفيقها من قبل الشرطه في عام 1908 في نفس
التاريخ 8 مارس طلعت الالاف من عاملات
النسيج للتظاهر في شوارع نيويورك وطالبنا
وقتها بتخفيض ساعات العمل ووقف تشغيل
الاطفال ومنح النساء حق الاقتراع وتم
الاحتفال لاول مره بيوم المراه العالمي في
8 مارس
1909 في امريكا وكان اسمه اليوم القومي
للمراه في الولايات المتحده تذكيرا
بالاحتجاجات النسويه السابقه في نيويورك
ومن بعدها وصل الى اوروبا في 1911 وتم
تبني هذا اليوم
رسمي للاحتفال بانجازات المراه
عام 1977 بعد اعتماده من قبل الامم
المتحده وفي عدد من الدول بيكون فيها هذا
اليوم عطله رسميه للمراه مثل روسيا والصين
واوكرانيا وفيتنام ونيبال واذربيجان